huit assaillants sept sont morts le soir
même la plupart en actionnant leur
ceinture d'explosifs
frédéric donc pour l'instant il ya cinq
de ses assaillants qui ont été
identifiées formellement identifié
céline en fait ce sont des jeunes hommes
âgés de moins de 35 ans donc cinq jeunes
hommes même si les trois premiers en
fait ont vécu principalement en belgique
les cinq d'entre eux sont tous français
c'est important de le mentionner
qui sont ils vraisemblablement on va
dire de la classe moyenne par exemple
les deux premiers étaient propriétaires
d'un bar à molenbeek
par exemple ça miami moore lui était un
ancien chauffeur d'autobus donc
apparemment sans histoire sauf que ils
étaient tous fichés et connus des
services antiterroristes mêmes allons
plus loin en fait au moins quatre
d'entre eux se sont rendus jusqu'en
syrie dont vous voyez c'est quand même
assez important de la nationale entre
autres
alors évidemment il en reste un donc
salah abdeslam qui est toujours vivant
en fait pourquoi est il toujours vivant
mais les enquêteurs pensent qu'il n'a
pas eue n'a pas été capable d'aller
jusqu'au bout de son noir dessein c'est
à dire de faire un maximum de dommages
est vraiment de donner sa vie à la cause
ce qu'on sait c'est que il appelait deux
de ses acolytes qui sont venus le
chercher à paris l'aurait emmenée en
voiture jusqu'à bruxelles donc rien est
encore en fête officielle on ne sait
même pas s'il est toujours dans la
capitale belge
mais c'est en tout cas lui qui avait
loué notamment deux planque dans la
banlieue de paris donc à bobigny et
alfortville et c'est là en fait qu'il
aurait fomenté les derniers préparatifs
avant de passer à l'acte un peu plus
tard parmi les kamikazes il ya un syrien
oui ainsi rien en fait
on essaie toujours de l'identifier parce
que bon évidemment on a pu identifier à
grâce aux restes humains de son corps il
s'appellerait à matt helm en rame at on
dit pour lyon pense parce qu'en fait
c'est le passeport qu'on a trouvés près
de lui serait probablement un fonds
alors sept ans à qui un appel un appel à
témoin en fait de la police nationale
française
bon on envisage maintenant la
possibilité qu'il y ait un neuvième
assaillants quelqu'un qui conduisait une
voiture peut-être oui en fait c'est un
passant qui a filmé peu après la
fusillade sur une des tirages sur une
des terrasses
il a vu en fait qu'il y avait
des armes qui sortait par deux sonneurs
ce qui veut dire que s'il y avait deux
personnes
il le rend moins une troisième qui
conduisait la voiture donc c'est la
piste privilégiée par la police
actuellement pour faire avancer les
enquêtes
merci frédéric